hi I'm Patti Harrison huge bitch and I'm
joking booster and you're watching
unsend where we celebrate the best and
the worst of the web but mostly the
worst
[Music]
[Applause]
listen it's time to tackle a heartening
issue that rubs each and every one of us
the wrong way I'm not talking about Isis
I'm talking about Instagram pass ah the
worst AI says look we're going to
Instagram to gawk at shapely male bodies
and to find out what our ex alex is
doing did he book that Broadway show I'm
dying to know he will update me right
but these ads are coming at us every
other scroll down and it's pissing my
ass off you bitch language if you're
gonna invade our feet at least be better
than this Yakko ad look at this disaster
oh this fellow looks like he tried to
pledge a fraternity but lost his way
during Howie
I'm sorry Yacht PO but I'm reading and
rereading this ad and I still don't know
PO what it is you're selling yeah good
yeah before you boast about your 5,000
reviews maybe let us in on who you are
we don't know Jai Kisan we don't know em
VMT watches and we don't know you now
let's move on to the most nefarious evil
on this rat king of evil attractive
females peddling tea let's examine fit T
an ass like an ass and is made of cake
there is no better salesperson than a
big booty Judy these girls let their
asses do the talking and spoiler alert
I'm listening with my little pod out I
had an eating disorder for six years
we're here with the effortlessly cool
Jimmy o yang you can find him on all his
social media handles that funny asian
dude and he is a funny asian dude but
was he always a funny Asian dude I guess
we're about to find out when we dive
into your old Instagram posts in a
little segment we like to call defend or
delete we have this first post here got
my sag card in the mail today now
waiting for my vCard to arrive
hashtag acting hashtag sag Wow yo okay
most I got no problem with the post but
the hashtag
it's satisfied like this is I hope you
won they do hashtag set life
hashtag acting is so wild you think a
lot of people are searching hashtag
acting yeah when they're looking for
actors you know well know casting
directors yeah they I saw this is crazy
I saw Steven Spielberg on a laptop at a
coffee shop and I like kind of creeped
behind him and I was like what what's he
looking at he was on Twitter and
Instagram at the same time just looking
at hashtag actor hashtag set life
hashtag sag and was casting that's how
you found me
please hashtags I want to do a hash tag
set life guys huh see that's that's I
missed that hey to get my genitals out
for it to get likes good see ya wait I
get so many followers from the hashtag
set life next I just joined the hashtag
darkside wait this is all my yeah that's
you oh my god Jimmy you really threw
down and you thought and I've had whoa
on February 5th 2013 Jimmy o yang bought
an iPad oh it's alright
oh oh my was when I was 2013 and this
was like a milestone in my life oh you
know what some people are good and some
people are bad to the bone and they
don't have keyboards 2013 you got an
iPad you joined sag whoa that's a big
year for your free Jimmy it was it was
it was it was a big year you're gonna
see fender delete this I feel like it's
so bad and now people will see it on the
show I don't know if anybody watches
this show but if they do see it on the
show then I'm gonna look like an idiot
deleting this like oh I'm ashamed of it
so I might as well just like live with
it and might be proud of it you guys at
home I wish you find this post on
Instagram and like it and tell Jimmy
you're with him on the dark side honey
okay thank you so much Jimmy for coming
in today
this was so much fun we've learned a lot
about you and your stupid little brain I
really thought there were some good
photos in there and I think you're a
really cool guy and I think there's a
lot of cool things that you are going to
show us in the future I can't wait to
see what you do I love each and every
one of you so much I know that this time
is a hard time to live in but yeah just
keep going wake up every day
say I'm gonna do something that makes me
happy even if it's one little act of
kindness to yourself do that for me if
you do that for anyone else do it for me
I grew up a Christian and even though I
don't necessarily identify as a
Christian anymore I think that
spirituality is important and I hope you
do too thanks for watching unsent Joel
don't come in that
[Music]
you